I have not had a very good experience
with therapy and life coaching I feel
like when I have those conversations I
have to spend the majority of it trying
to provide context around whatever
situation I'm thinking through typically
in those types of relationships the
incentives aren't on line like their
incentives for me to keep coming back
and paying them my incentive is to be
done with this and so the only person
who can have absolute context and
absolute alignment for you is you I
remember seeing this quote once I was
like if you follow your advice your own
advice you'd already be way further than
you currently are and I thought about
that and I was like yeah I don't think I
need to follow anyone else's advice I
think I should be doing the things I
already know I should be doing